sí
tu materia favorita
artes ciencias deportes
muy probablemente tienes en tu mente
ahora un recuerdo y quisiera que lo re
tuvieras por el resto de la plática
vamos a construirlo a partir de dos
preguntas que quiero hacerte
qué te viene a la mente el primer poema
que redacta este y te diste cuenta que
la literatura es lo mejor que existe en
el planeta la primera vez que ingresaste
a un laboratorio hiciste un experimento
y te convenciste que la ciencia es
maravillosa
o aquella ocasión en que tomaste una
fotografía y te perdiste en las redes de
la cámara
la segunda pregunta que quisiera hacerte
es en este recuerdo quién está ahí
si miras a tu alrededor muy
probablemente hay una persona que te
está encaminando en este sentimiento de
sorpresa o de querer investigar más
acerca de este tema hay una persona que
te está tratando de demostrar y aclarar
tus dudas esta persona muy seguramente
es un profesor
inclusive si descubriste esta nueva
pasión desde tu casa o solo en algún
punto acudiste a un profesor y este fue
tu guía durante algún tiempo
este recuerdo estos momentos estos
instantes que tienes en este momento es
a lo que yo le llamo deslumbramientos y
en mi vida me ha sucedido dos veces
el primero de ellos me sucedió en
secundaria esta leyenda urbana de que la
materia de química es muy difícil que
muchos reprueban yo me la creí
finalmente me toca tomar esta materia
con una maestra y obviamente al
principio tenía mucho miedo pero con el
paso del tiempo con las clases que tenía
con esta maestra me di cuenta que tenía
algo muy diferente algo muy particular
esta materia
entonces me di cuenta que la maestra
tenía una pasión increíble al
explicarnos su materia que cuando
nosotros como alumnos le preguntábamos
nos respondía con una paciencia a pesar
de que éramos adolescentes
sin duda alguna note que la maestra nos
veía como los seres humanos no como un
disco duro al que hay que meterle
megabytes de información y hacerle pasar
un examen
ella nos veía de una manera diferente
entonces con esta nueva manera de dar
clases sembró en mí una pasión tan
grande al punto de que a mis 18 años
decidió estudiar ingeniería bioquímica
este fue mi primer deslumbramiento
la segunda ocasión que sucedió esto fue
esta universidad había un programa de
emprendimiento en el que por azares del
destino estaba en la lista y de todos
ellos yo era muy seguramente el que
menos sabía que era emprender que era
una empresa que era lo que era lo que
estaba haciendo ahí no lo sé pero para
este programa nos estaban dando unos
cursos ofrecían unos cursos para poder
prepararte para este programa decidió
meterme a estos cursos y es ahí donde
conozco a una maestra y un maestro que
al explicarte su visión
cuando méxico emprenda al unísono melo
contagiaron inmediatamente en estos
cursos me dieron muchas lecciones mucho
conocimiento de algo que yo desconocía
tal fue el impulso de hacerme
emprendedor que el proyecto que tenía
inicialmente se consolida como una
empresa a este momento yo le llamo el
segundo deslumbramiento sin embargo hay
algo en particular en esta historia
el emprendimiento o la empresa fracasa
pero yo como emprendedor me doy cuenta
que en una de las lecciones ellos me
demostraron que el fracaso es una
oportunidad única para replantearse
muchos de los aspectos de tu vida desde
la raíz y es ahí cuando ellos no se han
equivocado precisamente a partir del
fracaso surge un nuevo camino en mi vida
del que estoy enamorado y hasta el día
de hoy sigo aprendiendo muchísimo la
docencia
a día de hoy soy maestro del área de
ciencias en biología física y química
precisamente en un nivel bachillerato y
secundaria
en el espacio donde trabajo están las
cuatro secciones en kínder primaria
secundaria y bachillerato y convivimos
entre todos en alguna ocasión se acercan
unos pequeños y me dicen profesor
estamos haciendo un proyecto en español
y trata de hacer una entrevista y bueno
queremos hacerle la entrevista a usted
yo un poco desconcertado les digo bueno
tengo el espacio vamos a hacer la
entrevista por supuesto que sí dónde
quieren que hagamos la entrevista ellos
se voltean a ver unos a los otros como
si ya hubieran pensado la respuesta
desde antes y me dicen en su laboratorio
profesor se puede y yo bueno ok nos
vemos en el laboratorio llega el día de
la entrevista les abro la puerta van
ingresando al laboratorio y la carita de
maravillados de entrar a un lugar
diferente donde había esquemas átomos y
donde solamente los grandes entran pues
ellos quedaron maravillados y les dio
una energía muy bonita para poder
realizar la entrevista y fue un momento
muy ameno finaliza el tiempo se tienen
que retirar y antes de ello me dicen
profe antes de irnos podemos hacer un
experimento rápido sencillo y yo ya
sabía que se tienen que ir pero que así
casi a manera de cómplice dije ok
perfecto tomo el material necesario
el experimento consistía en mezclar dos
sustancias en el que una sustancia
blanca se torna a morado como lo has
pensado en este momento en la televisión
como te lo ha mostrado la tele hago esta
mezcla entonces
y la cara de los niños fue algo que
jamás en mi vida voy a olvidar
fue impresionante cuando ellos se dan
cuenta de esta mezcla se van contentos a
su salón y días posteriores me habla la
maestra y me dice profesor quiero
mostrarle las conclusiones de la
entrevista que le hicieron a usted yo
claro que sí ahí nos vemos llegó a el
lugar y a mí me parece maravilloso
cuando un alumno lee sus propias ideas y
las conclusiones fueron geniales pero
recuerdo una en particular que decía en
la parte de la entrevista y al final
dice y antes de irnos el profesor mezcló
una poción blanca con una poción y
entonces se volvió una poción morada es
lo mejor que he visto en mi vida
a través de esta experiencia entendí que
los profesores tenemos la dicha de
deslumbrar a nuestros alumnos y entonces
si generamos este deslumbramiento ellos
pueden detectar las habilidades y sus
talentos desde pequeños
a este alumno me parece lo deslumbre en
primaria a mí me sucedió esta secundaria
y universidad
entonces sí deslumbramos desde pequeños
a nuestros alumnos para cuando lleguen a
secundaria universidad como me pasó a mí
ellos serán expertos en la materia y
tendrán una pasión muy sólida
entonces así en nuestra sociedad cuando
estemos en la universidad o años
posteriores tendremos muy claro cuál es
nuestra función aquí en el planeta y
todo gracias a que un profesor causó ese
deslumbramiento
en un estudio de una maestría en españa'
menciona que un profesor debe tener tres
características muy importantes para que
sea el profesor ideal la primera que
tenga pasión por lo que enseña la
segunda que sea justo y la tercera que
valore lo que tú haces bien como alumno
sin duda alguna el valor del profesor es
causar estos deslumbramientos para
detectar e impulsar el talento y las
habilidades de nuestros alumnos que
mejor que desde pequeños y a ti quién te
deslumbró